هلا هلا هلا هلا هلا بالعمر
لحظات للتاريخ عاشها كله محبا للمنتخب
الارجنتيني وهو يرى افضل لاعب في العالم
بلا منازع يحمل الكاس الاغلى كاس العالم
ومن غيره البرغوث ليونيل ميسي
عقدته الازليه ومنهيا صيام سته 36 عاما
لمنتخب بلاده عن تحقيق البطوله الابرز في
عالم كره القدم انتصر ليونيل واطلق
الكثيرون على البطوله العالميه المنتهيه
لقب بطوله ميسي التي حققها بعد فوز مثير
على فرنسا بركلات الترجيح بعد تعادل
ايجابي في اللقاء بثلاثه اهداف
حمل الارجنتين على عاتقه فحمله زملائه
اللاعبون بقلوبهم لرفع الكاس سويا ولتاكسي
قطر والمنطقه العربيه مونديال التاريخ
سيبقى في ذهن ميسي وعشاق الكره 100 حتى
النهايه بعد نجاح تنظيمي ورياضي كبيرين
[موسيقى]